find the some Express the answer is a
simplified rational expression and state
the domain so we have these two rational
expressions or two fractions if you will
and whenever we add fractions we need to
find a common denominator and the common
denominator has to be something that's
divisible by both of these denominators
and in general we want to find the least
common or the smallest the least common
multiple of these numbers or the
smallest number that's divisible by both
and when you look at it immediately it
might pop out if you liked hey you know
what G 6 is divided is divisible by 3
and X to the fourth is definitely
divisible by x squared so 6 X to the 4th
is definitely divisible by 3 x squared
and of course is divisible by itself so
this actually is the least common
multiple this is the smallest number
this is the smallest number or the
smallest expression I guess that is
divisible by both 6 X to the 4th and 3 x
squared so let's make that the common
denominator so this sum is going to be
equal to 5 over 6 X 4 plus and now what
we want to do what we want to do is
write this with 6 X 4 as the denominator
so let me just write it again so plus 7
over 3x squared so how do we make a 3x
squared into a 6 X to the 4th well we're
gonna have to multiply it times 2 to
make the 3 into a 6 and I'm gonna have
to multiply it times another x squared
so we have to multiply it by 2 x squared
now we can't just multiply only the
denominator by 2 x squared that will
fundamentally change the value of this
expression we can only multiply it by 1
so let's multiply it by 2 x squared over
2 x squared and we're assuming here that
X is not equal to 0 X does not equal to
0 and that was actually a safe
assumption to make that X is not that 0
is not a member of our domain right from
the get-go because that would have made
either of these expressions undefined so
if we assume X is not equal to 0 we can
divide to it we can multiply by 2 x
squared over 2 x squared and then that
will give us so this will give us the
expression 5 over 6 X to the 4th plus
this becomes 7 times 2 is 14 14 x
squared over 3 times 2 is 6 x squared
times x squared is x fourth so now we
have a common denominator the common
denominator is 6 X to
for and we can just add the numerator so
it's 5 plus 14x squared or I like to
write the higher degree term first or
14x squared plus 5 and we are assuming
that X that X does not equal 0 because
this would make the expression undefined
and that's about as simple as we can
make it we can't divide you know 14 is
divisible by 2 and so is 6 but 5 isn't
so we can't divide everything by 2 and
then there's x squared X to the fourth
but 5 has no X term on it so we can't
divide everything by X or power of X so
we're done it's 14 x squared plus 5 over
6 X to the fourth and X cannot be equal
to 0